we're halfway home into the 2014 st.
Louis Invitational and we had some
unique games today much more decisive
than yesterday as well in the tough GM
feel the Grandmaster elect Cade entro
won his first game of the tournament
against been fine gold Kayden's
situation is unique as he is not in this
tournament to achieve a norm rather to
get his rating above twenty-five hundred
do you have all your general Ike yes I
have the I have that approved so all the
norms have been approved it's just
pending rating but in my last tournament
because how it works is if you hit the
if you hit 2500 at any point so you get
the norms and then you have to hit 2,500
at any point even on live ratings which
means in the middle of a tournament so
in my last tournament I actually hit 24
99.5 before the last round and so how it
works is fita actually rounds up so that
basically means i was at 2,500 but not
technically you know there's a few
different things here but I thought just
Queen takes here and at first I thought
oh he can't play rook vieques here and
I'm threatening rook c8 and stuff but
I'm like oh wait he just plays here rook
c8 and the night on d 7 is really
helpful on Bishop fa he protects ba he's
threatening b7 not really what I wanted
and so I played 9 a-4 instead again just
starting to break my queen out if he
just plays some waiting move so he
pretty much has to play reggae and now
take take rook c8 and hey bishop f8
takes and I have a rook and bishop and
two ponds for a queen which is okay but
I'm also threatening his rook so now if
he plays like a takes b5 I take
say night takes and play here and I have
the two rooks in a pot and he has to be
careful with this beep on kids that's
also going to be in trouble and I
thought that should be pretty good for
me and so he asked the kind of player
create and now rook takes day 6 and this
this just looked excellent for me III
don't know I don't think he could have
really done much now that we got to this
point because I have the three pawns my
vision my two bishops are really strong
my night on a four it is pretty well
placed okay Queen d5 rook see one it's
just all my pieces are kind of coming
into play g5 I think he was just trying
to complicate it but ok I played Fisher
Bay 5 so after g4 I play Knight d2 98
and now I played Bishop d3 next I want
to play Knight c3 and you know not
really allowing him to play Queen f5
having ideas of Bishop before and here
he was under a minute so it's hard to
blame him and this just tough position
probably just lost he played queen bee
three and now after Bishop c4 Queen
takes a four of course is the main line
but now just Bishop you want and his
Queens just trapped on a four so he has
to go into this end game which I mean
the G pawns also hanging but he's just
down to ponds say if he takes just down
to ponds and I have the two bishops it
looks really good so he he tried to play
rook c8 but now just take and ok after
take just 91 my bishop protects my night
and it's game over the last names in
lighter yellow are unable to achieve
their norm in this tournament however
it's not elimination rules it is a round
robin so they play until the end in our
second tournament Doug Eckert also
scored his first win of the event
scoring a big win as white against Shawn
vivid I have no norms
I've you know been a non chess-playing
working professionals so this is
something I would like to do but we'll
see if it happens but when he played
Bishop d5 I thought that was really
risky because he's got a problem on f7
now and the variations are complicated a
computer may figure out a forced win
here but for example in this position I
was thinking about playing Queen to e2
with the idea of Bishop takes d5 in
Queen f3 hitting f7 I also thought about
Bishop takes d5 but it was hard to
figure out exactly whether or not this
was winning in this position so i looked
at sea takes d5 Queen to d2 here and I
couldn't figure out if I was winning
this or not he plays d 4 and then Queen
up for and it's tricky I mean maybe this
is the right way to play but I saw this
line Queen to d2 where I have this rook
sacrifice on f7 and I didn't see a way
for him to avoid this particular
position and at worst I'm going to draw
this position I mean because his King is
so exposed but it's very very hard for
black to play this in time pressure so
he plays a great move c5 so he's
threatening to check and trade Queens
and then he's okay so i brought my clean
in the corner he checked so now i have
to be careful about bringing my rook off
the back rank because rook that ye one
is mate but again this is practically
very very difficult for black to play
now he plays another good move Queen c6
otherwise I was going to play rook to d1
and queen age 7 check and he should play
King f6 here and then I've got to see if
I have anything better in this position
than playing Queen H a check which is a
draw I would probably look at playing
Queen to h6 with the idea of Queen f4
check but again it's not easy then after
his King gets back to g7 to do anything
to
because I've got to be careful about my
own back ranked but but he played the
final air here King f8 I think he just
overlooked I now have rook down Shack
because if he takes the rook I I just
play Queen h8 check and I went as Queen
and that would be the end of the game
there so now we're in a situation after
you know he missed that he has to bring
his King up and it's doubtful as a
defense for black at this point it would
be tough to expect Doug to win all four
of the next games in a field such as
this but that's what he has to do to get
his IM norm we hope you're enjoying the
coverage of the 2014 st. Louis
Invitational remember you can check out
every single game as it happens live at
11am and 6 p.m. central time at st.
Louis chess club or
you